welcome to part two of our episode on
using Auto elemental vision
if you miss part one you'll definitely
want to watch that first I've included a
link to that in the description below
okay so in part one we talked about what
Auto Amell vision is used for and what
the data is expecting
we also gathered and prepared our
training data now let's see how to use
our data to train our model that's just
as simple as clicking train I'd
recommend starting with the simple model
first of the two choices and seeing how
it performs after training is started go
for a walk grab a coffee it'll take a
little bit of time and we're back once
training completes you'll get all sorts
of statistics about your model which you
can use to see how it performed and
whether there were some images that were
perhaps mislabeled or other aspects
worth correcting and then you can
actually click retrain to fix those
things in our case since we gathered
very specific and clean data by design
we got some astoundingly high metrics
however what really counts is how this
model performs on new previously
never-before-seen data I took some
pictures to try to challenge the model
see what I would return let's try this
picture
it contains the bike along with yellow
and blue chairs and ok so that image was
recognized as primarily the bike but
it's got a little bit of yellow and blue
chair in it as well there in the
background and far less prominently
featured in this photo does that make
sense let's try another this picture is
mostly yellow chairs but there's a
couple of blue chairs in there and the
model thinks it's seeing mostly yellow
chairs with a bit of blue chair and how
about this photo of mostly blue chairs
yep that's mostly blue chairs and it's
got a splash of table and interestingly
a bit of yellow chair which is not
expected so not everything is going to
be perfect with a machine learning model
but so far this models top option has
proven to be quite good now finally
let's take a look at this picture
very similar to the previous one
but the front chair is now a yellow
chair what will the model think of that
Wow look at that
the yellow chair in the foreground
really won out big time it's got a way
higher score alright enough playing
around with those pictures for now note
that this model is already available at
this stage to be called via its REST API
all we did was train but it actually
deployed it for us as well the service
leverages cloud ml engines online
prediction capabilities to provide an
auto scaling prediction service that
serves a customized model trained on our
data set the neat part about all of this
is that once you have your data pipeline
worked out from raw data to well-formed
CSVs the process of training and
deploying machine learning models is
completely hands-free in that you don't
have to write any code just click and
wait this allows you to focus on getting
your data in a good state and hands off
the challenges of constructing a
suitable computer vision machine
learning model to the service thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it hit
that like button down below and be sure
to subscribe to get all the latest
updates right ah nayfeh Mountain now I'm
gonna go and find me some more colorful
chairs to take videos of so I can expand
my data set for my Auto ml model